Hey, how's it going?
Today I'm gonna take a few minutes to
talk about InfluxDB,
Flux and Tables.
This is a response
to a question that I came across on
Twitter on InfluxDB from Tyus.
Hey Tyus, how is it going?
And Tyus said, I'm doing a from range
filter pivot filter sort.
Why are the results not being sorted?
And this is actually a really common question
and it just comes down to understanding how
flux returns as results as a set of
tables
and not as a single source of data
and we'll look at that as an example.
Now the answer here you can see in
my reply is just to flatten those tables
with an empty group.
So let's
use an example from my own data.
So what I have here is my InfluxDB.
It is where I store all of the
metrics from the videos that I produced and
upload to YouTube
and
what we can see here is if I
just know, click submit to show this is
fresh data is that we have a set
of results
here and a single table. You know, zero
zero zero zero zero.
With the name of the video
and how many views that has received and
aggregate across all 10 windows.
Now, in order to show why this is
necessary,
I would just take out
some of this query. Right? When we're moving
a group assignment group and a top which
is just a sort and
a
top end filter.
Now, what we can see here is, well
we still have a table zero but now
we have a table one, table two,
table three
all the way down to table
97.
And this is because
we are getting the default group key
which is on the tags within the bucket.
This was much better explained
visually.
So
what we can see is you know classic
time series data here and that each of
these lines represents one of my videos and
how it performed over time
and that uses the tags within the bucket
to work out what the group will be
by default. In this case it is the
video ID.
So
one of the things that we can do
is, you know, say I just want to
sum,
no longer, I'm no longer getting what we
would consider time series data because we're not
looking at a time or window. I'm using
the default group key
and calculating the total number of minutes viewed
for each video. So there's no time dimension
here anymore.
Now,
you can still see that that some happens
on the default group key which is per
video. So I still have my 97
tables.
This cannot be sorted
and because the sort happens with an inside
of each table
and in fact if I bring in the
top end,
you'll see I still get 97
tables
because the top end also works within the
table
and the only way to get around this
or to get something that you can aggregate
across all series is to do a flat
group.
When I bring in this and I'll take
out the topic in for a moment,
you'll see we get one single table with
97 entries, 97 records.
Now we have a data and a position
that can be sorted because it all lives
in a single table and in fact if
I bring in my top end again, we're
back to the initial query
and we can see
exactly what we expect.
So what does that mean?
Understand that Flux returns things
based on the default group which is the
tags within the data and you will get
one table for each unique series.
Any filter, any sort
that happens
at that level is per table.
If you want to work across all the
tables with all of your data you need
to do the flat group and then you
will get the results that you expect.
I hope that helps, have a great day
and I'll speak to you soon.